a good afternoon uh this is ee 380
stanford university in the spring of
2022.
um
the
talk today
is uh
about converged ai
and
hpc it's a hardware and software
approach using rock's tensor streaming
uh
processor uh this is uh
and
fascinating and interesting talk i've
read a couple papers about it
and i think we're in for
for a great ride
the speaker is the uh
principal architect at grock and uh he
was previously at
google and before that at cray
he's a graduate of the united university
of minnesota
and
a
highly respected and very productive uh
[Music]
producer of uh new parts and
architectures
uh
he has a great first name by the way
it's dennis
we share that and uh now i'm going to
share my screen with him
and uh we'll see what happens dennis
euron thank you very much for doing this
okay thank you dennis for that nice
introduction i'm glad to be here uh as
you mentioned today's talk is about
converged ai and hpc and it's really a
an introduction to both the chip micro
architecture and the system architecture
as we scale from chips to systems and be
able to describe some of the work that
we've done in the past several years and
as we uh launch our new uh set of
processors in the market
uh to kind of describe what we're doing
and why we did it kind of describe the
motivation so that people get a sense
for uh why we made the trade-offs that
we did
as dennis mentioned my name is dennis
axe i'm the chief architect and uh
fellow at grock i've uh been at grock
for for a few years and uh i
met uh jonathan ross the founder at well
my tenure at google i spent
about a decade at google building data
center networks
focusing a lot on energy proportional
networks as well as uh
very scalable cluster architectures
prior to that as dennis alluded to i was
a chief architect at craig where i was
worked on several top 500 machines and
uh brought to bear a lot of the uh
distributed shared memory and what we
came to know as as a dragonfly topology
that that is currently kind of used in a
number of state-of-the-art top 500
machines
this dock is also uh prepared with oscar
menser so i want to thank oscar for all
the help
especially this week as a little bit
under the weather he was very very
helpful in pulling this all together
what i'm hoping to do is use this as a
little bit of a retrospective to give a
little bit of our uh
past work from iska 2020 where we
introduced the chip micro architecture
to describe
uh the the uh deep learning accelerator
that we built called the tensor
streaming processor
and then on this this isca coming up
here in the next month we'll be
releasing a new paper that describes our
system architecture it's called a
software-defined tensor streaming
multi-processor for large-scale machine
learning
and that's a fairly descriptive title so
you can get a picture of what it what it
entails but it's really these two papers
kind of
elucidate both the chip micro
architecture and the system architecture
so i'm hoping that you will
be encouraged to go and read those
papers to dive in for more details and
if you're really encouraged to come and
talk to us because we are hiring and
there's lots of interesting work to do
so um i want to just stop and and take a
step back and in a nutshell describe
what brock does we we're a nascent
company we've been around for the last
six years
our flagship product is as mentioned the
tensor streaming processor
and the compiler a parallelizing
compiler that goes along with that and
we'll talk a lot about the hardware
software trade-offs that go into
building a large-scale machine like this
like i said we're a relatively small
company we've got around 250 employees
and we're growing every day and i would
invite each of you to take a look at the
grock home page so you can see if
there's anything that would be uh
conducive or fit what you're looking to
do
brock is a a uh uh
spread kind of all across the the
country and across the world we've got
offices in
london as part of our acquisition of the
max eller
acquisition as well as all over the
united states and toronto we have a
large
facility in toronto
where a lot of our compiler engineers
operate out of and of course our
headquarters are in mountain view
california
we are remote uh first so if you if you
embrace and like the hybrid working
environment we certainly embrace that at
grock and um i would encourage you to
take a look
so part of this i want to give you a
little bit of a background and maybe uh
motivate some of this talk by by
describing some of the work that that
really happened several decades ago and
in fact i would say we're at somewhat of
a renaissance in in computer
architecture and that old ideas are now
new again in some respects and um there
are several ideas in here that are
inspired by
uh the cray one and inspired by other
machines that are literally decades old
but but their time is is come and the
killer app is now uh machine learning
and so these domains
specific accelerators are like a new
generation that's building on uh some of
this prior work
and like i said 1980s spawned some
really fascinating work that was driven
by
uh dataflow and in particular there were
some fascinating machines and the j
machine i've got the picture here of a
1024 processor element j machine uh that
was um from from mit one of the
inspirational machines and it was really
uh founded on on some some
inspirational work that jack dennis did
around dataflow architecture
and it was based on this idea that you
could represent programs as a collection
of nodes
that are the operators like plus minus
multiply and so forth and the arcs or
the edges connecting those nodes is the
operands that are feeding those operands
and results
and so as a result you can compose
a function
a function for example a binary function
that's consists of two inputs x and y
and some of those those inputs have
tokens on them and that's the data
operands as they arrive
and there's a fundamental idea in data
flow and that is that the inputs as the
inputs arrive your your operator can
fire only when its inputs are available
okay so the idea here is to try to
expose as much natural concurrency
instruction level concurrency as you can
as you construct a program graph and so
the program was represented as a
computation graph or a program graph
and it really represented kind of from
the inputs to the outputs what was being
computed
and their data dependence relationships
in other words what had to be done prior
in order for these other things to be
satisfied
so in effect you you built this nice
graph and that graph
was very composable in that
you can build
more elaborate graphs by chaining things
together
and this idea really allows you to try
to expose instruction level parallelism
now if you look at this simple example
for instance instruction level
parallelism in this case is any any
siblings that is things that are
operators that are on the same level can
be executed concurrently so it gives you
a very natural way of exposing that
concurrency and exploiting it
a nice way i like to think about this is
if you were to think about your
computation graph whether that's
tensorflow or an onyx graph or any other
program graph that lists and respects
the dependencies if you were to pick it
up at the output and kind of dangle it
so that all of your inputs are dangling
there
you would you would nicely
the length of that program essentially
gives you your execution time and you
very nicely get a order of relation the
order of operators that need to be
conducted to respect that data
dependence and it gives you all the
things that can be done concurrently i.e
those things that are at the same level
so in this way it gives you a nice
representation of all the instruction
level parallelism that can be exposed
one of the interesting things about this
is it came about these machines didn't
ultimately didn't really have the
concept of a program counter per se
because
programs were represented slightly
differently they were represented
by this notion of a graph now obviously
we're fetching and executing
instructions so the execution model was
very simple you fetch instructions you
execute those instructions when their
operands arrive you update the state you
fetch new instructions and so there's
this kind of very simple execution cycle
that was used in this this simple data
flow execution model
and it really
emphasizes i think for the first time it
really emphasizes that communication and
computation are two sides of the same
coin and by that i mean if you're going
to compute something it is usually done
with the intent of communicating that so
that somebody downstream
an eventual consumer could use that data
in a way in a productive way and compute
with it
so it spawned a whole new set of kind of
uh aha moments for computer architects
as they took this to the next level for
example berkeley active messages i like
to
to look at that and say berkeley active
messages kind of the idea to carry this
to a network of workstations idea where
you have messages flowing on the network
and they're going to spawn uh new new
messages
and so this this whole idea kind of
quickly mushroomed and created new new
architectures in the 80s and early 90s
that uh really have have come to be
influential in today's
uh
domain specific architectures
so if we take this simple model and we
just extend it and we include a
interconnection network now the
interconnection network is kind of a
nebulous
topology agnostic way of representing
that we have some collection of
processing elements
and they're going to be consuming those
those uh consuming tokens or data
operands and producing new results and
those results
are going to flow on the network along
with the operands
and so the interconnection network is
really a fundamental part of all these
processing elements whether it's on the
same chip or whether it's off the chip
it's a fundamental part of this
execution model
so what i hope to to describe today is a
really a very different approach that we
took and that's really a
software-defined approach
and by that i mean we very carefully
laid out the hardware software interface
so that we have an isa
that is about um
it's about controlling the underlying
hardware most instruction set
architectures are designed to abstract
away the details underneath the heart in
the underlying hardware for example on
an x86 you may execute a load effective
address instruction well you don't what
you don't see is all the implicit
messages and the cash moving in the cash
movements and all the implicit data
movements that get
orchestrated as a result of executing
that in other words often they get
broken down into little micro operations
that orchestrated together as an
ensemble
accomplished some larger goal
and so that is going to be one of the
themes today we're going to talk a
little bit about that of how we've
decomposed or disaggregated our
functional units so that we can break
things up into smaller micro operations
that we can execute efficiently
along with that hardware software
interface is a
static and dynamic interface in other
words we have a runtime system that is
going to be used for
um actually in placing the the
collateral and placing your object files
on the machine and then invoking the
actual parallel application as well as
handling exceptions we'll talk a little
bit about exception handling as well
and in this regime nodes in the
computation graph represent the
operators just as we did we talked about
in the traditional data flow
and the edges represent results and
those fire only when their input
operands are available
and this turns out to be a very
conducive model for machine learning in
machine learning many machine learning
models are known a priori this it's a
static compute graph and you're taking
that static compute graph and you're
compiling it for the underlying hardware
like i said the the goal here is to
expose the the controls so that the
compiler or most notably the compiler
writer has complete control of the
underlying hardware and that was one of
the goals of of the the isa was turning
over and exerting control over the
underlying hardware not abstracting it
away but making it practical for the
hard work to compile or to to compile
for it
so that that required some design
philosophy and some some perspective
change from our from our perspective
because one of the things that we wanted
to do
is make a completely deterministic chip
so that the compiler
had omniscient information about
where everything was on the chip for
example
we allocate tensors on the chip the
compiler will know exactly where those
are in the sram as well as which
functional units are currently busy on a
cycle by cycle basis in other words the
compiler literally can track the state
the architecturally visible state
on a cycle by cycle basis
and you might think well that makes it a
lot harder to build a compiler but the
reality is by turning over control to
the compiler it's managing more meta
state more architecturally visible state
but it has complete information about
the state of the machine and it can now
use that to reason about correctness for
example memory consistency and memory
ordering things like that and it can
reason about program correctness now in
a way that allows uh the compiler to
build uh build a program efficiently
so part of this was we had to embrace
this concept of determinism and make
sure we did not do anything in the
hardware that would reorder events for
example there's no out of order
execution there's no caches we don't
have traditional caches
we have no arbiters this is the 14th
chip that i've designed and worked on in
my career and this is the first one that
doesn't have any arbiters
and by arbiters i mean it's a crossbar
where you're presenting some data to it
and it's going to
arbitrate and grant one of those inputs
an output port for example
there's other reactive components for
example link layer
replay uh the pcie point-to-point
network uses a link layer protocol to
replay any retransmissions that happen
and of course that interferes with
determinism so we had to embrace forward
error correction on our data paths and
we had to account for all that and when
we designed the system both at the chip
level and at the system level so we'll
talk a little bit more about that
those specific tradeoffs
so the way that to look at this is we
want to turn over control of the
hardware so that the compiler can have
this
screen programming model it's a producer
consumer screen programming model
which just means that we have this
concept of a stream register instead of
a normal general purpose register we've
got this concept of a screen register
and i'll describe that in much more
detail as we uh as we go
because it's a central it's a central
concept and it's a central hardware
structure
and and the compiler can track the state
of the stream registers on the chip and
know exactly where everything uh is
located
so imagine waking up in the morning and
this is what your morning commute would
look like this is the concept of
determinism to your morning
hopefully your morning commute doesn't
look quite that busy but that's an
example if you didn't have stop lights
as a flow control mechanism how could
you orchestrate your traffic well this
is exactly the job of the compiler in
this case is that in that we are going
to turn over
um and and do and change the way we
think about the normal uh cpu in fact
what we've done is we've avoided some of
the complexities that would ordinarily
go into a cpu for example a lot of the
front-end dispatching and scheduling
that would go into a normal cpu think of
thomas hilo's algorithm checking for and
remapping different registers shadow
registers all of that goes away instead
we're we're
turning some of that complexity to the
compiler to deal with that scheduling
instead
that's a much more amenable place to
deal with that for a variety of reasons
um number one it it offloads some of the
the complexity the logic complexity if
you look at the the uh the floor plan of
the chip the dye above you see there's
it's a it's a regular design but there's
a number of of control units on it if
you look at the the chip on the bottom
it's very very regular very structured
and we take advantage of that and i'll
i'll explain why in a bit in a bit more
but it dramatically simplifies the the
chip design so that we can focus on
the alus and the data paths that are
driving them so that we can put our foot
on the gas provide a lot of on-chip
bandwidth to feed all those hungry data
functional units
so one of the things as i mentioned
often gets in the way in a traditional
cpu or gpu is a conventional memory
hierarchy
so for example we don't have a
a memory hierarchy what we have is a
single level
sram that is organized as a flat
memory a large 220 megabyte
i want to say cash but it's not a cash
it's a single level explicitly managed
memory system
and it uses the concept of a
memory slice or a memory bank for
concurrency in the memory system there's
a um 88 banks each of which can issue a
read and a right so in principle there's
up to 176 way bank level concurrency
that's a tremendous amount of
concurrency and we're going to describe
kind of how we use that for both
instruction fetching and for all the
data operands and results that we're
feeding to our functional units we take
really good advantage of that
to be able to drive our
our large matrix units and vector
processors at full rate
um so again this is based on this
deterministic latency and explicitly
allocating tensors in memory hierarchy
and then we expose that that sram that
220 megabyte shared sram across the
distributed system so you can think of
having multiples of these in a logically
shared but physically distributed system
okay
at the system level we tried to simplify
some things to avoid uh introducing a
lot of complexity for example modern
supercomputers scale to tens and 20 000
10 10 000 20 000 nodes very regularly
and those are very heterogeneous systems
they often have cpus gpus smart knicks
uh fpgas a variety of offload engines
that are really very heterogeneous and
difficult to coordinate and and often
very difficult to manage the error
handling along with it because it's
often so heterogeneous they all do
something very different for the error
handling
so one of the things that we did is we
we uh build direct network so uh our
single chip both provides the processing
elements as well as the switching
elements for the networking component as
well so that single chip
does both the networking and the
processing and so that that
allows us to simplify our design have
fewer components uh as well as build
very straightforward direct networks and
i'll talk a little bit about that direct
networks in other words we don't have a
nick and a switch chip uh and that
that's doing the routing instead our our
single chip is doing both
so and and one of the differences is we
are
literally scheduling the links instead
of having a a loosely coupled network
interface where we just kind of do an
rdma request and it just goes off and
works on it in the background and then
notifies us when that transfer is done
instead we are scheduling the physical
network links as a first class citizen
just like we would do the vector
processor or the matrix process or any
other on-chip resources and this is a
fundamentally different way of handling
the network and handling the way that we
uh we think of the overall system
so again i'll describe kind of the the
idea here but it was really trying to
get rid of some of the waste fraud and
abuse both at the chip level and at the
system level and one good example of
this if you were to look at this this
chip uh our chip i'll show you a
detailed die shot here in a moment but
the overhead for the instruction control
is less than three percent that's less
than three percent for all the
instruction dispatch and um uh the what
would normally be kind of the front end
of your instruction dispatch pipeline
so how do we do this and why is it
different and what i thought i would do
is start with kind of the canonical uh
five stage
pipeline that we all learned while
reading patterson and hennessy at our
mother's knee
it's got a instruction fetch decode
execute memory and write back
those are the fundamental stages and
what we do is each each one of these
tiles you can think of it and this is
just kind of a
an example of a of a mini core
architecture and just to contrast our
approach with the with this this more uh
more conventional approach if you think
of this as a a collection of of course
what we did is we disaggregated those
cores we took the the functional units
the integer and the floating point uh
that are your your your workhorses for
the alus right they're doing fixed
precision and floating point uh numerix
and we took the instruction dispatch we
made that a separate union unit we made
all the the memory system a separate
unit we literally disaggregated all
these units to provide a simpler
instruction set for each for example we
have a memory unit this is uh the
kind of salmon color or pink color here
the memory system only does loads and
stores gathers and scatters
that's it it can do fetches instructions
it executes them it doesn't do ads it
doesn't do
transcendental functions it just gives
loads and stores gathers and scatters
along with no op and instruction fetch
obviously every unit has to instruction
fetch
um so you can see what we did is we
disaggregated and we made these
pipelines very specific so what we kind
of did you think about we have a
separate memory unit so we disaggregated
and decoupled the memory access from the
execution units that is the vector units
the matrix units the
switching elements that are going to be
operating on that data this decoupled
access and execute allows us to have
thousands of outstanding vector
references in flight and keep the memory
system pipeline heavily pipelined and
we'll talk a little bit about that as
instructions get executed
core to all this is the idea of a stream
of streams flow on the chip as you can
see they flow in the east and the west
direction
and this is the idea of these stream
register files and that they're the
stream register files allows us to take
the what would normally be you think
about a general purpose register
and uh if you were to think about like a
mips processor and you do a load of some
address into a general purpose register
say i store it and register two
i can come back three weeks from now and
you'll still have that value and
register too unless something bad
happened you had to reset the machine
in a streaming register file when i do a
load and put it into a stream it's
moving so the next cycle it's going to
be moving on the chip and so as it flows
out on the chip it's going to pass by
every one of these functional units in
the same way that an assembly line
passes by all the different stations
as it passes by we can pick the data up
operate on it and then put it back into
the screen so it can continue in the
eastward or westward fashion
that's the very simple idea behind this
concept of a stream register file and
screening stream programming that
results from it what it does is it
allows us to build an efficient producer
consumer model where you're producing
into streams and somebody else
downstream is consuming from those
streams
operating on the data and producing some
new value
so the chip is organized using this that
this concept of a super lane as i
mentioned it's broken up into tiles into
these functional slices you can see
vertically
you've got different functional units
vertically and horizontally these are
different super lanes so you can think
about we took all the normal functional
units within a core and we kind of
disaggregated them and spread them out
across the super lane we'll look closer
at that in a moment
but what it allowed us to do then is to
execute
instructions in a cycle by cycle kind of
a staggered manner cycle by cycle so
it's
pipelined vertically in instruction
execution and it's pipelined
horizontally in data execution so this
thing is pipelined in two dimensions
vertically and horizontally so as you're
thinking about this try to imagine
tensors flowing in kind of flowing in
the horizontal dimension and
instructions are being dispatched from
the south to a northern way uh in a
northern manner
this die shot shows the different
functional units i just want to take a
second to point these out at the book
ends here we've got these big mxm arrays
our matrix multiplication units um and
these are 320 by 320 so there's
literally they store 320 320 byte size
weights so that's a total of 100 and 2
400 weights in each and there's four
instances of that on the chip one two
three four
so there's over four hundred thousand
multiply accumulates that are on the
chip and we use them to generate a 320
element
fused dot product okay and i'll visit
that again because it's an important
concept it's a fuse dot product and then
we're taking the 320 elements and
computing the the sum and doing a single
round off so we don't lose too much we
don't spill too much numerical uh
accuracy as a result of repeated round
offs
all of this really combines to give us
what what is the goal of this
initial chip was as much compute density
uh per silicon area as we could and that
that we hoped in turn to add value to to
our customers right so the goal was to
expose as much computational density and
communication bandwidth so that we can
build scalable systems from it
in the center of the chip we've got our
vector processor our vxm and it sits
right at the the center of the chip for
one reason it has a lot of bisection
bandwidth right at the center of the
chip we've got streams going east and
streams going west and so we can keep
the vector processor fed completely
fully fully fed
as well as you can see along the outside
of the chip is where all the ios are
we've got a pcie gen 4 interface to talk
to the host a host cpu
and we've got these chip to chip links
these chip the chip links are ringed
around the outside of the the chip and
that's what we use for building scalable
networks from
all right so as instructions execute
from this south to north like i said you
can you can kind of visualize them as
having different um little micro ops for
example and i'll give this example again
we might do several things for it for
example at time 1 we're going to read
some tensor onto a stream
at time 2 we might add some bias to that
tensor and we're going to flow that to
our sxm unit which is our switching unit
and the sxm unit does shifting it does
lane permutation think about moving the
elements within the vector
and then lastly maybe we'll install
those weights in the mxm perform a
convolution or a matte mall and then at
time five we're going to take those
results and write them out to memory
this shows you how we're able to kind of
chain those small operations together
and the conduit through which they're
chained are the streaming registers this
this this notion of
a streaming registers uh is what allows
us to kind of very efficiently take the
output from one and chain it to the
inputs to another so that we're not
going back and forth to main memory so
this allows us to do kind of these more
complex
operations with only a read and a write
at the very beginning and the end of it
at the center of a domain-specific
architecture is a domain-specific
instruction set so as i mentioned our
our chip is disaggregated disaggregated
into the different functional units and
those functional units correspond to
instruction control
which is the icu which is the the small
little sliver we're constituting about
three percent of the chip you look down
here it's literally down here in this
little
region down there that is the
instruction control that's dispatching
uh instructions across 144
independent instruction units on the
chip
there's a memory functional unit that
does as i mentioned reads and writes
gathers and scatters along with that it
has an address generation unit and this
address generation unit is a way for us
to very efficiently encode
very regular strided references in other
words if you have a known access pattern
that looks like kind of nested loops
then you can very easily represent that
with just two or three instructions to
to capture the stride and that reference
pattern
the vector processor does a bulk of
heavy lifting it does all the point-wise
elemental operations
it has what you would expect a variety
of add subtract multiply uh reciprocal
square root
it has activation functions such as relu
tange
it also has some transcendentals as well
so uh the mxm is the
the big the big functional units that
are sitting at the east and west you
know as bookends on the chip and that it
it does very little i like to think of
it as a big and dumb functional unit
it's a very big functional unit it's
very simple in that you can install
weights you can
apply activations to it by controlling
the activation buffer and that's about
it it generates results
very very efficiently and it's like i
said a very big
very efficient but
limited functional unit in what it's
what it's doing
the sxm is our switch execution module
and that does
um all the data shifting data
manipulation and movement within the
vector and across vectors so we think
about
shifting
vectors north and south permuting
vectors
to create a bijective map a permutation
map as well as a distribute a
distribution function so think about
your communication your communication
hierarchy as i can move data within the
super lane very inexpensively but as i'm
moving data further in other words
moving data across super lanes is more
expensive
um so there's there's
operations for example like rotate and
transpose which are strictly within the
super lane allows you to be very very
efficient so you can do a for example a
16 by 16 transpose in just 16 cycles so
you can take 256 elements and turn it um
you know rotate the columns and and rows
very very efficiently in memory
and then lastly we've got our chip to
chip where our communication uh links
and this these have
just a handful of instructions to send
receive and then there's a
unique one here that's called
d skew and that is so that we can manage
the uh what we call the skew across
those links and that is to keep them in
a lock step uh manner to give the
illusion of a synchronous communication
fabric
of course with that instruction set
comes a data type support
we support several of these data types
natively in hardware and i outlined them
here in yellow and that's int 8 and uint
8 as well as float 16. so the big mxm
units can operate uh natively on signed
and unsigned integer as well as
floating point data
again unique to this is these are 8 or
16 bit
inputs that are accumulated as either in
32 for integer arithmetic or fp32 so
we're accumulating to a more precise a
higher a larger precision than the the
inputs
so all of this is kind of motivated some
some interesting trends and it really is
again coming from that the concept that
communication and computation are two
sides of the same coin
more importantly as we see by this this
graph from mark horowitz issc issc
keynote uh several years ago
um it's a little bit dated but the
concepts here are so important i just
want to i want to re-emphasize it uh and
and point out that this was was really i
think a turning point and really
embracing this data parallel approach
really helped kind of move machine
learning into to that realm of the new
killer app for these kinds of domain
specific architectures
um more importantly um there's an energy
difference the dramatic energy
difference between adding 8-bit integers
and adding floating point numbers for
example or multiplying data compared to
adding data there can be an order of
magnitude difference but often a 4x or
2x difference so you want to choose the
right data type that provides the most
energy efficient solution
that satisfies your your accuracy
requirements
now remember we're we're we're using
these data types so that we can
represent some hidden space in a in a
machine learning model all of which is
being um characterized and representing
a larger state space that that will have
some accuracy to it and again the idea
is to to provide the highest accuracy
with the lowest precision and therefore
have the best energy consumption
and this is a nice example of kind of
where the energy goes the actual energy
to do that computation is often quite
small but the energy just accessing the
register file
accessing your operands
the control unit to actually dispatch
the control and do the decode is often
expensive and the actual cash access is
often
an expensive component as well
so
part of that is we have a simdi
uh cindy um 320 element uh execution
model so that we can amortize that
control overhead
across 320 elements it allows us to take
advantage of data parallelism where it
exists and where we can efficiently use
it within tensors
okay so as i mentioned the the
functional control units are
disaggregated but at the heart of each
one of them they all have to support
several
uh several you know native instructions
one of which obviously is instruction
fetching they all have to fetch
instructions they all have to support a
noaa
and the no op is a special instruction
here because it occupies time it
consumes one cycle
so it is the means by which the compiler
will coordinate
the arrival of the data and the
instructions that are executing on it
as data is is
flowing east and west the instructions
are flowing north and as the two
intersect that's where the action
happens and so the instruction is
executed the data is used to um
process on and we can
use the stream registers to communicate
the results between the different
functional units
very important here is two instructions
for
on-chip synchronization and that's the
sync and notify the synchronization
instruction
allows a uh an icu to park so it parks
the icu and it waits for a different icu
or from the host either either one to
to notify or wake up all those
functional units and that's necessary
because as the chip comes out of reset
all these different functional units 144
functional ants are all loosey-goosey
and they're all independent and and
they're not coordinated so they have to
be synchronized bring them to a
synchronization point and then after
we've notified they kind of like
released release the hounds and they're
all uh in lockstep at that point and at
that moment forward the compiler can use
dead reckoning think about they know the
exact location of everything and every
instruction and every piece of data on
the chip and they use that dead
reckoning to figure out where every
piece of data is
going forward
okay so let's look at and punch into
what this super lane looks like as i
mentioned the super lane
is the the unit of kind of the base unit
in which the chip micro architecture is
based on
a super lane you could think about
taking the functional units that are
common in a mini core
either the memory unit the data movement
the network interface and all the alus
and we spread them out across the super
lane and now data is going to be moving
east and west on this super lane so that
we can take advantage of that data flow
locality as it flows past
so again the base the base unit here and
you can think about where we're taking
our tensors our large uh large um you
know multi-dimension tensors and we're
breaking them down into a rank two
tensor and that rank 2 tensor
will fit on the underlying hardware here
so the inner dimension the maximum we
can do is 320 elements the outer
dimension is is you know
nebulous
it's a streaming time so you take the
inner dimension as your vector length
the outer dimension is your streaming
time so for example a 320 by 1024 matrix
is represented by 320 element vector
streamed across that for 10 24 cycles so
it allows you to have two dimensions uh
in in hardware
at the center of the chip is our vector
processor and the vector processor is
really it uses this this 320 lane
abstraction
and we we fit 16 vector processors in
each lane so the way you can think about
this
is logically we have 320 elements that
are that are flowing like uh flowing
through the chip and we've got 16 vector
processors that can intercept and use
those to do various point wise element
uh operations on them
now in practice now in in that's the
logical you know architecturally that
that they're viewed as as you know
16 kind of in the same lane but in
reality they're organized as this kind
of 4x4 mesh because they have to be laid
out on the chip and we organize them as
a 4x4 mesh you can chain them all
together to get this logical kind of 16
vector processors in a single
lane it provides a lot of flexibility it
is a big workhorse it does
all it supports fp32 operations as well
as fp16 as well as int 8 um so it
provides it provides a variety of data
type conversions and of course all the
activation functions
uh for example so so this gives a nice
example of how you might map a simple
operation that does a uh
an accumulation followed by an ad a relu
and then a conversion a cast
operation and it shows how those might
be mapped to different alus
and all those alus have access to the
streams again
that's the idea is that the streams
represent the conduit through which we
can chain and share and and be able to
uh communicate those uh results very
efficiently
continuing with this um the super lane
i'm gonna plunge in and just talk a
little bit about the memory system now
remember i i mentioned that the memory
system is highly concurrent and in
particular
the the memory unit is broken into two
hemispheres each hemisphere has
44
banks of concurrency
a total of 88
banks of concurrency
and um the reason we we have so much
memory concurrency is we have 32 streams
going east 32 streams going west as well
as all the instruction fetches and io
that we have going on so the streams
help
the screen bandwidth as well as the sram
bandwidth helps to
keep everything fed at full rate
and so you can see the the um we call
these quads not surprisingly there's
four four memory banks in each one and
on each side of it you'll see these are
the different stream registers that i
mentioned and so as you load something
into memory it literally starts flowing
in an east or west direction and it
starts flowing in these stream registers
so that's when i mentioned if you do a
load in a normal jeep general purpose
register you can come back tomorrow and
it'll still be there in this
architecture if you do a load you better
have something to do with that data
because it's moving and so if you don't
do anything with it it literally just
going to fall off the end of the chip so
the idea here is you you have to have
something in mind you're going to load
some data you're going to do something
on it and maybe you're going to store it
or do something beyond that but you have
to kind of think about how how you're
going to use that data
the switch execution module as i
mentioned uh this is kind of the swiss
army knife of of data movement and that
includes
a distributor that allows us to very
efficiently do onto mapping so we can
take take any of the 16 bytes within the
super lane and we can rearrange them
with with utter impunity we can just
shuffle them up
uh we can take the transposer and we can
do
um different transfer uh trans transpo
transpositions either one by one four by
four or 16 16 by 16 transpose
we have a permuter and a shifter and
that permuter allows us to do an uh an
arbitrary a bijective mapping so to take
your 320 elements and to do a bijective
map maybe we're going to reverse them
for example and it allows you to flip
them entirely around using this this
permuter
and similarly it has a shifter that has
uh very very common operations to shift
these tensors up or down and you can
shift in zeros for example the zero pads
and some vectors uh as an example
and it also has uh you can see the
little tx and rx blocks here these are
the transmit and the receive side and
that's actually what's driving the
chip to chip links so our chip to chip
links are scheduled just like our mxm
and our vector and our sxm and memory
our units are they are literally
scheduled uh and this is very different
than than literally any other
conventional cpu or gpu out there that
uses a nic that's very loosely coupled
right you you program up some rdma work
request and that that's going to cause
some amount of work to be done on your
behalf
so let's jump in to the system
architecture now that we've got a little
bit of our bearings about the chip
architecture
let's jump in and see how this all ties
together to build scalable robust
reliable systems at the system level and
we start by just kind of recognizing
that we have to take this and package it
into a packaging hierarchy and this
packaging hierarchy is really important
because it's going to constrain your
topology choice and your your um
how many how many pins you can escape
for example so so it's really an
important aspect of making your topology
and your packaging nicely impedance
matched
so the objectives of our topology are
really multi-fold we really want to have
a low network diameter
and we want to build a direct network
like i said we're going to be building
the from the same building blocks here
it's going to be our processing elements
and our switching elements it's going to
be both and we use that to build direct
networks an example of a direct network
is for example mesh taurus
flattened butterfly dragonfly uh an
example of an indirect network would be
a full glow or a factory for example
where you've got a endpoint and you've
got a switching element
and then making that a packaging aware
topology is really important so what we
did is like i said the contrast with
direct networks or indirect networks
where you've got routers and processors
our processors and routers are kind of
co-mingled and when we use this
to create a direct network that we call
a software scheduled direct network
and it's really a key the key
distinction because we're not routing
packets we're scheduling tensors on
those
links
the other thing that's very different is
our
flow control instead of the flow control
being kind of credit based and you sense
congestion and push back on the host
when you overdo it in other words you're
going to pile a bunch of things in the
network and let it work its way through
it until it gets congested and then it
starts to insert back pressure in the
form of explicit congestion notification
or ecn messages pause frames if you're
running on ethernet
and that back pressure is going to
ultimately uh hurt your performance as
as you stop stop uh stop processing on
the data waiting for the tree saturation
to resolve and then starts flowing again
instead what we do is
we essentially control or paste those
links in software so software knows
exactly how fast we can drive those
links and no faster we can operate them
up to about 96 efficiency by pushing
them all the way up to that limit um but
going further would would cause dropping
of packets right so we can we can take
it all the way up to the end
and of course all this is really fit
into that packaging schema so you can
see we've taken a chip we've combined it
with a heatsink and mounted it on a card
and we take eight of those cards and we
fit them into a node
and the the idea here that we're trying
to expose and exploit is the concept of
packaging locality things that are close
together can communicate inexpensively
and abundantly and we have
literally 28 links these are all to all
so these eight eight tsps are connected
in full in a fully connected way to each
other so if you look in here there's 28
uh links in these little low low profile
uh
uh chip to chip links and then we put a
hood on it to kind of hide all the the
sausage making and we stuff that into a
rack no that rack has a total of
uh
nine nodes in it we we have eight nodes
plus one what we call a spare redundant
node that we can take advantage of in
case we have hardware failures
so the low diameter network is really
important because it really drives to
the first order your overall system
performance so what we want to do is be
able to build as large of a network as
possible with as few hops and then what
we want to do is relax that just a bit
by taking
one additional hop to do non-minimal
routing
and by non-minimal routing what i mean
is if you think about you think about
the network you can take any two tsps
into an arbitrary source destination
pair there's exactly one minimal route
between them
but there may be many in fact there is
many many uh mult there's multiple
non-minimal routes between them so
that's the the idea here is we want to
use those non-minimal routes
to take advantage of all the available
bisection bandwidth
so the dragonfly topology is a
hierarchical topology that takes into
account the packaging structure to try
to match the packaging with the topology
and create what's what's known as a
virtual router and so we use our node to
build a virtual router that's 32 ports
on each virtual router
and that allows us to be able to connect
those nodes up in a in a global system
and share those across
across the broader you know distributed
system
um so
that's the idea and allows you to kind
of think about this from a local
topology and a global topology again
these are hierarchical so they're fully
connected within the local group
and fully connected within the global
group
the local topology here has some
constraints and that has to have some
amount of internal speed up so in other
words there's more internal bandwidth in
the in the local group than there is
globally because we're going to be using
that local as a as a virtual switch and
we're going to be routing some traffic
through it
and then the idea here is to go from a
single tsp and we can scale all the way
up to uh at the largest configuration
over ten thousand tsps in a system
okay so we've got abundance amounts of
both local uh
local bandwidth and global bandwidth and
each
rack has a spare note in it so that's
how we kind of deal with
redundancy and reliability in a
deterministic system remember i said
we're gonna have to make some tradeoffs
along the way one of the those
trade-offs affects our redundancy and
reliability
faults and handling those faults and
exceptions are notoriously
non-deterministic right if we knew when
all the faults would happen we could
account for it but we don't and so
cables fail power supplies fail chips
fail and we have to have a means to
handle that
the way that we handle that is if you're
running your inference and your
inference fails
the runtime system can replay it and
kind of kind of replay it once to see if
the problem is kind of a persistent
failure or if it's a transient value you
might have a a simple uh you know bit
flip that that is transiently resolved
if the if there's a more permanent type
of failure
replaying it doesn't fix it then you can
migrate that to a different node
and and choose a different set of nodes
to run the application on and this is
where the topology and the symmetry of
the topology matters the dragonfly is
very nicely both edge and node symmetric
contrast that with a mesh for example if
you had a mesh in your note and your job
got laid out on that mesh if you got it
if you happen to get unlucky and be on
the edge of that mesh you have less kind
of indra you have less bandwidth than
the other nodes do so it's very nicely
uh symmetrical
and we use that to provide a a
reliability story and reliability uh
redundant node that we can have the
runtime basically migrate and launch the
job on a good set of known good hardware
in the event of a failure
so how does this different than a normal
uh a normal rdma request let's just
think about what happens in a normal
rdma request we start at time zero and
we have our processor
right to the nick to to describe some
work request some dma request and it's
gonna go off and do a remote request to
read some address
it's going to send that over to the
remote side where it's going to hit the
memory controller and it's going to do
some reads in the memory controller and
that's going to cause some replies to
start flowing back
those replies are going to flow back all
out across the network and then we'll
finally at time 5 get the data back and
we'll be able to use it so there's a
very request reply protocol here in
place and those protocols usually
use different virtual channel buffers to
guarantee deadlock freedom because it is
a protocol you can't have replies
blocking requests
um and that's a that's a fundamental
idea so you have
virtual channels to to
to uh
disentangle your your requests and your
reply data
our
communication
model is much simpler in that the
request is never sent instead the
compiler knows when the data needs to
arrive
and simply pushes
uh via kind of a send
so the destination is doing a send and
the recipient is doing a receive and
he's just going to know that this data
is arriving at this time and then it
gets used
so so there's no explicit request
traffic flowing across the network you
can kind of think of this as just reply
only traffic where the request is being
implicitly communicated through
metadata through the compiler right the
compilers is essentially scheduling that
the the read request
so the network as i mentioned the
network that extends this concept of
single chip determinism across the
entire system so we needed explicit
instruction level support to support um
to to give this illusion right and
basically what we're doing is we've got
all these tsps that are cooperating but
they might get out of sync with each
other and by that i mean these are
plesiocrinous links so they they have
some tolerance and that tolerance is is
really determined by the crystal that's
driving their their their clocks
and so if you're using a crystal with 50
parts per million you would expect them
to over a million cycles they might
drift 50 cycles or so okay so you kind
of think about these things as roughly
in lockstep within some kind of epoch
within some window but not a hundred
percent within lockstep and we kind of
we use that to our advantage to provide
the illusion of synchronous
communication
even though occasionally we have to tap
the brakes and make sure that everything
is synchronized okay so instead of
instead think of it this way if
if you're if your your processing
elements get out of sync the first time
you hit a barrier
this you're going to end up incurring a
bunch of waiting time because you're
going to be limited by the slowest link
and the slowest link is going to come
along sometime later and he'll satisfy
that barrier
well when they're all in lock step when
you hit that barrier you satisfy that
barrier almost instantly and that that
allows us to avoid all the waste fraud
and abuse that ordinarily gets
accumulated to your barrier waiting time
and that's a huge huge benefit of of a
synchronous communication model
so i just described a little bit here of
the isa support specifically have
several
key pieces of hardware hardware
alignment counters and a software
alignment counters
as well as again those instructions the
sync notify desku
uh and then to be able to do this
runtime d sku so the way that we we
structure this is is we set up the the
network at the time the job is invoked
we synchronize everything and then the
runtime kind of does this periodic
de-sku to make sure it's it's still in
lockstep as the as the program executes
so every five milliseconds or so tap the
brakes make sure everything's kosher and
then proceed and that gives you um a a
very you know a minimal synchronous
communication fabric that you can use
uh to communicate without the need of a
lock
and by that i mean if you think about
how you would communicate in a
distributed shared memory machine you're
going to have a producer that's going to
write some data he's going to do a
memory fence to make sure all that data
is globally visible
and then he's going to
modify a flag variable that says it's
now safe to consume that that chunk
and the the consumer is going to be
busy waiting on that flag variable and
they're going to see the change in it
and say okay i can safely consume it now
we don't require that additional lock
variable we're literally going to be
producing data and we're going to push
it out to the consumer
and the consumer will know when it's
visible because we use time we have the
concept of global time and that the
sender knows that at time 4273
he's done writing the data and the
receiver can now safely consume that
data at the same time
4273 or whatever that number happens to
be so we're able to use time in a way to
provide a lock-free communication fabric
and that is just critical and very
different than how a distributed shared
memory
semantics work
all right so
again all of this is really
driven by our compiler and a bare metal
programming interface and there's really
two two ways of interfacing with with
the chip like i said first of all is a
compiler we have an auto scaling
parallelizing compiler what does that
mean it means that you have some model
that's gonna ingest that model and it's
going to see how many parameters you
have and then spread it across enough
chips to be able to fit you have to fit
that model
and then you're going to schedule that
on the underlying hardware
we have a bare metal programming
environment that allows us to have
basically complete and utter control of
the hardware at kind of the isa level at
the very lowest levels if we want to to
very explicitly control it if you if you
don't want to operate at pi at pi torch
or tensorflow you can write these custom
custom applications using our bare metal
programming interface
and then as i said at the bottom here
we've got this hardware software
interface that's really being managed by
the runtime system
so if you think about what a parallel
invocation looks like we're generating
um we're generating multiple
collateral files multiple uh files that
need to be installed on each tsp
they need to be synchronized and then
the parallel program is invoked by the
by the runtime and then the runtime just
kind of stays plugged in to make sure
that there's no exceptions if there's an
exception the runtime has to respond to
it right
um one of the one of the unique things
about this as i mentioned we had to
think about exceptions and how we're
going to handle that so that we can
short-circuit some of those for example
how do we handle arithmetic exceptions
if you get a uh an overflow for example
we don't want to have a uh a a
alu that doesn't add that causes an
overflow that would produce a carryout
flag for example or an overflow flag if
you're familiar with
other architectures
um instead we choose a priori we choose
what we want the semantics to be either
saturating or modulo and and for example
you know you often will use saturating
so that if you're if you're doing some
alu operation your gradients saturate at
a certain point they don't roll over and
they don't you don't overflow or
underflow them so it avoids some of the
kind of uh exceptions that you would
have in the wild because you decide a
priori how you want to handle those
those arithmetic exceptions should they
arise
so again the this concept of a bare
metal interface or a bare metal program
is really built on layers of abstraction
at the bottom is really our assembly
language which is uh taking taking the
the raw instruction api
and it's compiling it and producing the
the program out the program collateral
the object files if you will on top the
instruction api is what we call our
tensor api and you can think about just
operating on normal tensors like you
would take tensor a and tensor b and add
them or concatenate them or split them
for example and then on top of that is a
very familiar neural net library that
you would see in like tf conf you know
constitute we have a nn.com
nn.matmall or uh average pool for
example so there's there's the neural
network library that kind of sits on top
of that
again the the idea here is we want to
make this an efficient target for the
compiler
but obviously the compiler isn't ready
on day one so we had we have multiple
ways in which we can kind of program the
chip depending on your your use cases
and depending on your application for
example celeski factorization is a is a
high performance computing code that is
very common in doing uh linear algebra
and we take a symmetric positive
difference matrix and we take that and
we spread it across multiple chips and
then we chew through that very in a very
efficient way using vector matrix math
and we can
get very good performance out of the out
of the out of the system and this shows
you kind of how we scale across multiple
tsps
um ultimately this is kind of a
a large problem it's an n squared kind
of problem so as the matrix grows it
becomes harder to fit onto a single chip
so we we outgrow a single chip around
7000 elements so we need to start kind
of spreading it across multiple chips
there's other other applications here
for example natural language processing
with bert
this is a nice example and and just to
kind of show you the the
the benefit of determinism
is
you look at our histogram of latency and
it's a it's it's virtually this
perfectly straight spike of just a
single value
and there's a small amount of variance
because when we're reading inputs in
from the host
occasionally the host can take a hiccup
and and have to replay one of those
inputs and that that is part of the
non-determinism that i mentioned earlier
that that we can't get rid of that
that's just part of pcie we have to kind
of live with that so we set up the chip
to be able to tolerate that and be able
to kind of manage that non-determinism
interface so we have kind of this this
well-defined interface between the host
cpu and the tsp itself
and so we flow that inputs onto the chip
and once it's onto the chip then we
start processing and it's completely
deterministic from that moment on
uh and we can we can uh execute it with
with certainty
it's it's kind of an interesting
observation and ten years ago quality of
service or qos was a really sexy topic
for a lot of research and in systems
architecture
providing predictable quality of service
and predictable service level agreements
uh was really important to be able to
build scalable clusters
after all your internet scale
application will be limited to the
slowest link in the network and that's
what we really want to be able to do is
provide quality of service but we do so
from from determinism this this concept
of deterministic execution really is a
great way of guaranteeing some hard
quality of service limits
again let's look at gem a gem is a
workhorse of a lot of machine learnings
where we're doing matrix multiplication
and you can see that depending on the
size of the matrix being multiplied
there's there's certain kind of hardware
fitting you can think about it as
there's certain hardware characteristics
that get exposed
at different boundaries right and this
is a nice example of looking at kind of
an a100 where you see some of that
hardware fitting um taking place right
and so one of the things that we try to
do is be
very resilient to that kind of hardware
fitting and work across a wide range of
if you sweep through that matrix size we
want to be able to operate efficiently
at all those different operating points
so this is really a sweep through those
different matrix sizes looking at how
our our matrix multiplication utilizes
the uh the mxm
uh across the the sizes to get a sense
as to how sensitive we would be to um to
certain uh antagonistic sizes if you
will
and then we've been making progress as i
said you you start with the compiler we
started with
the compiler from from first principles
and that informed our hardware decisions
our hardware trade-offs
and then of course the compiler isn't
done on day one when you tape out but
but that it matures with time and the
number of models and the generality of
it grows and this is a nice example of
kind of that growth
that growth as we're able to add more
models to it add more generality and um
be able to tackle more sophisticated
models so we're making great progress
and the compiler isn't
a wonderful way to kind of
get your design input into it and get it
mapped to the underlying architecture
so hopefully i've kind of motivated some
of the trade-offs that we made
along the way talked about the stream
programming to be able to do compute
intensive deep learning and we really
bring to bear this predictable and
repeatable performance and you're
probably saying to yourself self
aren't all computers predictable and
that you get the same answer over and
over again
and the answer is well kind of and if
you just want to convince yourself of
that take a take an array of floating
point numbers and add them up just take
take a million floating point numbers
and add them up
and then reorder those numbers and add
it up again and see if you get the same
number
you won't get the same number on
floating point you'll get the same
number on integer because they're
associative but floating point numbers
are not associated
so
making that both predictable and
repeatable over and over again you get
the same result in the same amount of
time
so it's repeatable both in space and
time and if you've ever used the system
with caches you know that i might get
the same answer but it might be slower
the second time depending on if i got
some pollution or collateral you know uh
conflict cash conflicts from another bad
actor or if there's os interference a
variety of things kind of confound and
intermingle in ways that collude in in
in ways that prevent it from being
exactly predictable so that
predictability and repeatability is
essential when you want to use this chip
to do control systems for example
manufacturing control systems um very
time critical latency sensitive control
systems
it becomes a really really important way
of managing the complexity and managing
the
bounds on which uh the the control
system
and then really determinism was a means
to an end to be able to bring about this
vision of software-defined hardware we
had to be able to make the underlying
chip predictable the compiler needs to
track every piece of data as it's
flowing on the chip and that had to be a
hardware and software philosophy that we
had to embrace from first principles
and again here the isa is not about
abstracting away the details but it's
really about expressing and controlling
the underlying hardware and we do that
with 144 independent instruction control
units these are separate fifos that is
effectively represent your straight line
code that you're executing
and these 144 instruction cues can can
consume over two terabytes per second of
fetch bandwidth so in other words if
we're keeping everything busy we're
going to be churning through two
terabytes per second of instruction
bandwidth which we have to keep fed and
that's an awful lot for a dram
controller but it's it's not much to ask
of our sram with over 60 terabytes per
second of sram bandwidth it's a very
small fraction of the overall
main memory balance
and then again we expose these
architectural uh
screen registers and all the sram as
well as the instruction buffers so that
the compiler can completely reason about
program correctness from from beginning
to end when the inputs arrive and when
the outputs are generated
so we've extended this uh this concept
of a single chip tsp determinism
in that very kind of lock step execution
we've extended that to a multi-processor
to do software scheduled networking and
really that's that's really where we get
the value from our system approach is
we're able to schedule our network links
both minimal or non-minimal to use all
the bisection bandwidth in the system
and that results in really great all
reduced uh all reduced performance i
apologize i don't have a nice chart
showing the all reduced performance it's
in the the pre-print of the paper i'm
hoping that this will inspire you to uh
attend or at least read the isca papers
from 2020 and from
upcoming esca paper in 2022.
again all of this was intended to uh
enable a synchronous communication model
so that we can build these large scale
systems and then keep the overall
diameter of the network down to just a
handful of microseconds so that we can
make
using these these large scale systems
efficient
and uh and cost effective
i want to thank you for uh for enduring
with me this was a long talk and i hope
you found it useful and i want to
encourage you to reach out to
thegrok.com and look at our careers page
and see if there's anything that's
exciting to you
um if you want you can grab a capture of
that that'll take you to the grock.com
site and i appreciate everyone's
attendance and their uh their attention
i'll take any questions
if you're old enough you've seen this
talk before
um which is not bad but which is not a
bad thing because it was a great it's a
great idea every time it's come up um
you didn't mention a couple of things i
sort of expected
um
and that was
some sort is
where on your compiler chart was when
you introduced some sort of
virtualization so you could run a
problem bigger than your system
and
sort of the other question is
the the problem with data flow
is that you always run on the length of
the longest chain
and then it's a packing problem beyond
that
um
and
so you know conditionals are horrible um
so if you choose your problem right
packing works perfectly but you can't
run anything
and if you choose your problems wrong
then
you know the packing is easy because
everything's idle running no ops so
where are you
what problems are you picking so that
that works out to your benefit
um so i i if i understand that the crux
of your question here i guess it's it's
um you you view this as a big
two-dimensional kind of a bin packing
problem let's see if i can
get back to
we've got this two-dimensional die that
that consists of you know two dimensions
right we've got um
super lanes and and really what we're
doing is we're scheduling for the super
lane
and then we get we get the second
dimension somewhat free essentially free
that that's the the the uh the
instruction execution executes cycle by
cycle and so that that dimension kind of
comes for free so if you think about it
the compiler is solving kind of a
one-dimensional bin packing problem of
fitting everything into that super lane
kind of scheduling the functional units
on that super lane
rather than a more general
two-dimensional bin packing problem
which is obviously more complex
um and so you're you're you're right and
that you you have some you have some
functional data flow pipeline that
you're gonna you're gonna set up a
software pipeline right for example a
re-quantization pipeline you're going to
do some ads and multiply
a conversion um and then you're going to
do something well you start off by doing
a conversion multiply and add in another
conversion and you're going to set up
that fixed function pipeline and you're
going to stream your tensors across it
and then you're going to change that
pipeline
and the cost of changing that pipeline
differs if you're on a cpu you can do it
on a single cycle right you can change
instructions every cycle
if you're on a fpga right you have you
have you have a very fixed cost of
setting up a dif that pipeline if you're
on something like a coarse grain
reconfigurable computer where you have
some pipeline and you're going to set
that up and it might take you a handful
of microseconds to change that function
that becomes more expensive
what this is is it's the programmability
of a processor a gpu or cpu where you
can change the instruction every cycle
in other words that's why we need so
much instruction fetch bandwidth
but you can change that
on a cycle by cycle and you can do it
with with impunity every cycle you can
be doing a different instruction
in practice what we what we are trying
to do is essentially we have
multiple models co-resident on the chip
and you can kind of stack them all up
together very efficiently so that they
you know one model can for example you
might have some object detection that
feeds another model that's doing object
prediction and figuring figuring out if
the the person standing on the crosswalk
is going to take a step into the into
the the crosswalk for example
and so we can have multiple co-resident
models on the chip that allow you to
kind of very efficiently and quickly
switch between them with with with
virtually no overhead
um so that's one way you get at some
some virtualization of the hardware but
we also we virtualize at the system
level so the way that our virtualization
approach is to virtualize at the system
level think about virtualizing up
instead of virtualizing down instead of
taking for example taking a gpu and
breaking it into seven
logical gpus we we're taking a a system
of 64 tsps and we're going to take some
subset of that and carve that out and
call that a virtual cluster and we can
run some application on that virtual
cluster
and what we literally do then is we can
turn off any of the c2c links to
you know literally physically and
provide performance isolation and fault
isolation between those little sub
clusters those little virtual uh
subclusters
so the virtualization strategy is a
virtualization up at the system level
rather than taking the device and
breaking it into smaller parts that we
try to get better utilization of the
underlying hardware
i think i asked i think i
mis-set the
problem if i buy the smallest system
from you
whatever that is
am i limited in my problem size
it will take end times longer
because i didn't give you enough money
or am i just out of luck do i have to
buy the system for the largest problem i
will ever do or do i buy
a system and sometimes it runs slow
that so it's a great question so you're
asking if it doesn't fit on a single
chip can i trade off time
kind of batch it batch it and bring it
out in time and absolutely that's that's
the first step that the compiler does is
basically partition kind of what's going
to be running when and where so if all
you have is one tsp obviously
you you you you have to make that
trade-off right you don't have a choice
um but but yeah that's that's the idea
is you can bring that into smaller
chunks and work on it and and it takes
longer obviously
but if you have a system approach where
you can apply more tsps to it then you
can can take advantage of that
so dennis uh where are you in the
process here you're uh
uh you have uh design you have uh
first silicon yet
you have your shipping uh who's making
it uh what processed uh dimensions and
so forth you know the the standard um
uh
certification for uh
purchase
agreements
yeah yeah absolutely great questions so
we are shipping product now we're
shipping uh chips and nodes uh we're in
the process of of building up large
scale racks multi multiple rack systems
and deploying them in the in data
centers
so you can imagine that we can make this
available through a virtual private
server
and we can make make those systems
available
but at the moment we are selling chips
and systems up to eight-way nodes and
then you can take those nodes and you
can build larger scale systems from them
um so it is as you mentioned it is a it
is a journey it is a process and we
don't you know we don't start uh we
don't start life with everything well
baked right and you have to kind of work
our way into that so today we've got uh
systems with multiple racks and we're
working on building larger scale systems
to be able to tackle truly truly large
large scale problems but that's a
process and it takes time and it takes a
maturation process for the compiler so
as you see more generality more models
more
bigger models smaller models multi-check
models single chip models uh it's it's
all in a software maturation process and
we're making great uh great great
strides with that but this is something
today that that you can buy
one uh one or more cards or you can buy
a node that has eight cards in it and
you can buy multiple nodes that together
would be in a rack so it depends on your
use case if it's kind of data center
oriented or if this is something that
you're looking at deploying at the edge
again at something in a warehouse or at
a at a point of sale
or if it's something that might be um in
situ or in in a in an embedded
application like an automotive uh
application
so there's there's a number of of of
kind of depending on what your use case
is
i would say that that we are well along
that kind of maturation process
it depends on on how how large you want
to
how large you want to tackle
and this is uh
not a project a product that was built
for a single customer and
then expand it out or is it uh
a
private brand that's been published
totally branded or what
yeah so we're building this as a general
it's a general purpose accelerator i
mean it's generally enough to tackle a
variety of problems right it's not
uh it's not a resnet accelerator right
right just to make that clear um and in
fact at the time when we designed the
chip in 2017 uh transformers weren't uh
weren't really known and so
we had to design this to be generally
enough to tackle a variety of different
models
and
for example it's we designed it to be
really really efficient at matrix matrix
math
and vector matrix math and so if you
look at you know lstms rnns
convolutional neural networks we've
designed this to be very efficient at
doing linear algebra and whether that's
cholesky factorization or if it's a bert
model that it's doing vector matrix
operations and we can do that with
really efficiently and that's the that's
the underlying workhorse to all of this
so that's kind of what we were thinking
when we designed it is to build in that
generality so that it's not a one-trick
pony it has to be general enough to make
it very you know broadly applicable for
a variety of of use cases whether it's
by a fintech company oil and gas
exploration or by anomaly detection for
intrusion detection there's a lot
we don't want to
hold you to it but
can you give us a rough price uh bracket
uh for what what the cost of this is
going to be like
you know now
that's a great question i think we're
we're selling these for prices that are
consistent with kind of state-of-the-art
gpu so i think um it's it's you know
going to be along that that same price
line uh i apologize i'm i'm i'm i don't
have a price book or i'm not in sales so
i can't give you details on that but i
would encourage you to reach out and
talk to a salesperson if if that's
something of interest but you can
imagine that's it's going to be
comparable to a state-of-the-art uh gpu
yeah i i will read the papers i'm very
interested in particular
can you speak to or is it in the paper
the by
uh permutation you were talking about
um
yeah i think i can give a little more
more examples like i said uh if you look
at this green section here on the chip
this is our sxm this is our switch
execution module and if you were to look
at this this is a
a large on-chip network that that is
literally implemented as a
a
kind of a hybrid on-chip network that's
a combination of folded flow and a
vanish switch
and what we do is we can take we take
the input 320 and
out pops the output 320
permuted so you give it a permute
permutation map
you tell it how you want those to be
rearranged you give it an input vector
and a permutation map and it pops out
the output vector that matches that
and so that's just the most general you
know swiss army knife of data movement
you can do a lot of things with that but
that's also that's also moving that's
that's allowing us to move
320 elements across you know vertically
the entire check right so it's an ex
relatively expensive operations it takes
tens of clock cycles to perform that
whereas moving data within each super
link that is using the distributor using
the communication
locality idea that remember i said you
can do transpose and distribute and move
data local to the to the super lane and
each super lane is 16 elements and
there's 20 super lanes 20 times 16 is
320
um but you can move the the bytes within
the super lane with with with uh you
know really really efficiently and and
that's kind of just this concept of
locality of communication you can move
move things nearby really cheaply but as
you're moving things further it becomes
more expensive so moving things from
super lane 0 to super lane 19 you can
imagine is much more expensive right
we've got to traverse this larger
on-chip network
is it is it a single clock operation
it is a single core clock that is
driving the the entire uh
what we call kind of this core rectangle
which is just the
memory the mxm all of that operates on a
single
uh core clock that that um
and the the chip to chip links obviously
are running off of a a certain clock so
there's there's um
there's a clock domain crossing there
obviously
um and again we we had to kind of make
that all work one of the things that
required us to to to build into the the
design was the chip to chip links had to
use forward error correction and where i
said the link layer protocol cannot
retry things so you don't want the
replay mechanism interfering with your
determinism and so if you get a
transmission error you you need to have
a forward error correction that
recognizes that that that bit flip
corrects it in situ and your your fixed
latency pipeline remains the same so it
takes the exact same time to go through
it whether you had an error or not and
you pop pop out at the end of it you pop
out a a good vector a good flip right
it's corrected
and so that's that's the key idea we're
able to kind of
keep this idea of deterministic
execution and build it into the data
paths to make to make it all kind of
hold water you have to have this
consistent philosophy throughout the
minute you put one arbiter and you can't
predict where things are poof it all
goes away so you have to have this kind
of philosophy that that really stays
true to that
are there people out there who have
questions that we are not acknowledging
here
um i have uh two simple questions
and one
um more
maybe
um
[Music]
difficult question
the first two questions are
what is the power consumption and what
is the heat dissipation
okay um
those are great questions so the tdp
here is
is designed for about 350 watts
um in practice what we see for example
resnet i think is around 180 180 watts
it's workload dependent right um so so
in practice the the actual energy
consumed is far less than our our tdp
our tdp is designed to kind of be the
worst case that we need to to cool it
and provide the
provisioning for our cooling system and
our packaging
um so it's it's uh the eight
the eight
tsps in a node is about a three kilowatt
uh package and so that's your tdp of
that for you
chassis
and uh like i said depending on the
workload it's gonna consume you know 150
to 200 200 some watts typically
thank you my my more difficult question
is have you
considered
potential
in-ship
uh security threats and have you thought
about
how you
might
control for them
great question
um yeah security side channel attacks in
particular i'm assuming you're getting
out here if there's if there's ways to
kind of
um
to to do side channels one of the one of
those so no there's two questions one is
side channel and that's a very
interesting question by itself
but
because of the way
tensor models work
once they're once they've been
tested and
determined to be
to give
results within desirable ranges people
tend not to look at them again
and
so
one might wonder if somebody for some
reason would want to change the outputs
and
would want to
interfere
with the processing so as to produce
consistently different results
for some reason
it's a it's a great question let me try
to let me try to answer it so so two
things and i understand i understand
this this may be a little bit out at the
edge and it
but i'm not going to hold you too
absolutely
it's a it's a it's a great observation
it's a great question so a couple of
things when when we were designing the
chip and i remember spectre and meltdown
were all the rage this has just kind of
uh come out and um we they were showing
how up you know these aggressive out of
order execution can be used to
essentially set up these side channel
attacks and more generally anything that
you can use and and
generate different latency
um characteristics you can create a side
channel and use that varying latency to
impart information right
in our case the timing is all known a
priori and and anything that you would
do if you tried to for example if you
tried to put a man in the middle attack
to say
intercept some data
um it would change the timing
relationship it's a little bit of the
heisenberg principle here once the
program is built if you try to change
something it's gonna material affect the
outcome it and the program simply won't
behave as as it as it as it should right
it's going i mean that the timing is
important and you cannot perturb that
timing without changing its its result
and so it's kind of a heisenberg effect
if you put if you put someone in the
middle it's going to change the timing
and for example you're going to not
intercept the data when you expect to
intercept the data so your outputs are
going to be all wrong you're going to
get the wrong data back and you're
really not going to have observed the
thing that you
wanted to observe because
and the
is part of the mechanism so you cannot
use
temporal information to to extract
information about the side channel
question about um the speed the 900
megahertz is that in any way related to
what the memory will do or can you speed
it up or
what's the limit that you're looking at
there
great question so so we designed the
chip to
uh in principle operate up to a maximum
frequency of of uh up to 1.2 gigahertz
that that gets
unfortunately in in this packaging form
factor with amount of power that we can
dissipate we are constrained by the
clock frequency to kind of keep it
within that tdp
so
um i you know that's an artifact of this
is a big chip and there is such a thing
as dark silicon if you light it all up
at once you can start it all on fire so
you don't want to do that you have to
kind of control that and so our software
is is very instrumental in kind of
smoothing out any kind of didt events
any transient events so that we
don't have these large spikes these
large excursionary events and we can
keep the keep the lid on the heat and
keep the lid on on the on the uh the
performance so that we're on the heat so
we don't have to throttle anything back
right so we can operate at full at full
band at full
uh at full rate at 900 megahertz and
keep everything clicking along at that
in the pcie form factor so now as we
start to build larger systems you can
imagine where you have more efficient
cooling techniques to be able to
dissipate more heat and be able to
uh be able to do do a little bit more
with that um
you don't have to let your imagination
run too wild to to kind of see where
that's going okay what's the technology
here dennis says it oh fantastic
question this is seven nanometers or
what
this is actually a 14 nanometer uh 14
nanometer device
um you can imagine our next generations
are going to be uh smaller feature sizes
but this is actually a 14 nanometer
device and um we we uh we're quite happy
that we're we're getting such uh great
results with this and competing with um
you know truly
much more dense node sizes much more uh
ambitious node sizes in in competitive
products
okay
uh i'm from slack i i do a lot about pga
development now it's a fairly practical
question here is you've tied the uh the
compiler and the hardware together
fairly tightly so i'm interested in sort
of what the development cycle looks like
is this like an fpga when i go to
compile i'm looking at a fairly long
cycle to do this and what happens
uh do i have to describe the chip that
i'm going to
to the compiler in detail like you would
in fpga
fantastic question um great question so
so the compilation is
unlike an fpga where you're you're
essentially ingesting verilog and you're
you're doing going through a place and
route that is a much this is a much much
faster process for example it's a hand
it's literally a handful of minutes to
compile resnet for example or bert or
large so it's it's a it's a handful of
minutes and it's getting better all the
time um so it's it's much more efficient
than what you're probably accustomed to
for place and route and tool chains in
fact that's one of the things we are
really looking at doing is increasing
the the iteration rate that the compile
time has to be low enough so that you
can experiment in fact you don't need
any hardware at all to compile to get
your to know exactly what performance
it's going to run and even get some
estimates as to what power it's going to
take and so you can run the compiler and
without any hardware attached to it at
all just to get you to iterate quickly
on your model and get the the
compilation you know step
down entirely
with that you you you do choose your
target right you do you want a single
chip and what is that uh what there's a
topology
you know specification that says what
the network is that that describes the
the tsps underneath that you're
targeting that's but that's a you know
very lightweight and it's set up kind of
ahead of time and and you're just
compiling
your code and and the compiler is going
to ingest that look at how many uh tsps
it it has to spread it across to fit
from a capacity standpoint
um obviously you have to have that many
tsps in the system um to to be able to
actually execute it then
but importantly you don't need actual
underlying hardware in order to just
kind of compile and test out your your
machine learning model and that's really
key is that the time to iteration is the
time to innovation and just being able
to iterate quickly allows you to try
some things out to
to to be able to iterate quickly build
test and learn very quickly uh before
you even
install it on a piece of hardware
okay so as you move forward in your
hardware you will have to sort of
recompile your program
and i was thinking of like
your chip will evolve on a roadmap
it may have different architectural
features
that's right so as we add to the second
generation as we add different
functional units as we add more
uh more compute or we add more
communication the chip the the chip
organization will change and that's
that's just kind of an internal you know
internal between the compiler and the
underlying hardware that's kind of that
hardware software agreement
and that will change but but yes it will
entail recompiling um and and that's
that's you know we thought about having
kind of binary compatibility and it just
didn't make sense to kind of make things
backwardly compatible and especially
with these models if you can compile
quickly and make that as painless as
possible then it's just not as big of a
deal
yeah so so your market is is more or
less people with dedicated pros
dedicated things not somebody who has a
library of a thousand different
applications
well a thousand different applications
are great but you i think we have to
tackle them one at a time is the point
right it this isn't a kind of a kernel a
kernel-based approach right we don't
it's not like a gpu where we have a
kernel for you know image to call or a
kernel that does whatever x y or z
instead we have the parallelizing
compiler that is a vectorizing compiler
and it's gonna from first principles
take this disaggregated processor and
map your problem to these functional
units and that's a it's a it's a little
different approach than kind of kernel
based
just
taking a bunch of kernels and throwing
it at at the problem
okay thank you
okay so we're coming up to the end here
are there any more questions
um yeah thanks uh thanks for giving us
the talk today um i had one question on
the ctc links uh so you mentioned
forward error correction i was wondering
if there's a significant penalty
due to the added latency with the
forward air correction
and how you take that
it's a fantastic question so forward
error correction is um you know
compulsorily it does take some time
right and it's it's on the order of
hundreds of nanoseconds probably uh like
100 to 200 nanoseconds
so it does increase the latency of per
hop latency however we can
you know deal with the added latency we
can have everything pipelined and we can
hide that latency very nicely but it
does make each link slightly longer from
a
input layer you know from a flip in to
flit out
it does lengthen it a bit and so that is
one of the trade-offs of a forward rare
correction in in in poses um you know
and and going forward especially as we
get to 112 and 224 gigabit per second
signaling forward air correction is is
absolutely compulsory on these on these
channels right and so you're we're going
to have to kind of
it's a difficult pill to swallow i'll
let additional latency for the read
solomon encoding but we have to do that
to just to to to make these reliable at
scale
that's a great question we do have to
pay the latency the good news is we can
hide all that latency
and keep everything fully pipelined
hi again um
what is your compiler written and is and
do you have a formal specification and a
proof verified or you know
is it written in c
great question um so parts of the
compiler are written in haskell and
parts are written in c plus plus
and and i i would say parts of it uh i i
don't want to speak to the formal verify
verifiability of of it obviously haskell
is is strongly typed and there's a lot
of of
type safety that goes into that
so parts of the compiler are
strategically written in haskell parts
are written in c plus plus
okay i have sort of the pen ultimate
question then
and that is what do you do for the next
chip
oh that's a fantastic question
well i don't want to any spoiler alerts
here i don't wanna i don't wanna ruin
our our uh our surprises for the next
chip
um but not surprisingly you will
probably see
more uh more compute uh throughput
uh
and and really i i hope to to take
advantage of something that we're
uniquely capable of of taking advantage
of and that is this concept of energy
proportionality
and that's very it's a 20 word that just
simply means if you're doing very little
you should consume very little energy
and as you do increa incrementally more
you want to consume incrementally more
energy
and that seems like that's kind of
obvious dennis why aren't all systems
energy proportional
and if you think about the way a modern
multi-chip core is organized you've got
a shared memory hierarchy you've got
multiple cores and the moment you turn
on one core
you have to turn on all the shared parts
the l1 cache the l2 cache the l3 cache
the memory controller all the networking
ports you need to fire everything up so
it's not terribly proportional as soon
as you're doing 10
as soon as you have 10 offered load
you're consuming 40 percent of your
energy because you have turned at all
these shared things on
and that is fundamentally what we would
should be moving away from we want to be
really good stewards of of our planet's
energy protect our data center's pue uh
our energy efficiency at the data center
level
and we want to be good stewards of our
of our customers data and their in their
their electric bill right so energy
proportionality is going to be key as we
go forward and this is a a architecture
that is uniquely suited to be able to
make that a very incremental and energy
proportional endeavor without those kind
of
large clunky non-uniform uh energy
consumptions um so as as you can imagine
um
the number of lanes that we're using
is a very good heuristic as to the
arithmetic intensity required for
example if you were to look at resnet
the first layer of resin is 224 by 224
by 3 for the for the tensor dimensions
and as you go into the deeper layers it
gets smaller goes from 224 by 224 to 112
by 112 by 64 for example the tensors are
getting smaller spatially but they're
getting deeper okay and so
while the the tensor shape is changing
your vector length is is changing with
it so for example you might start off
using 224 of the 320 elements but on the
next
layer using a smaller fraction of them
say 112.
and so we want to consume energy that's
proportional to the amount of valid
vector lanes that we're using and so you
can kind of very simply see that this is
a very amenable architecture for that
kind of approach
okay we have chance for one more
question and then we'll have to call it
quits otherwise we'll say thank you and
go out is there another question
you've uh answered everybody's uh
questions
that's what happens you know
thank you very much it's a great ship
and you guys have done a super job it
looks like and um i'm just really
pleased that
it's out and uh people are beginning to
work with it
and
i know that
there's a lot of interesting problems
out there you'll be able to work on
thank you thank you
thank you it was my pleasure